- All right, y'all, we are back
with the one and only, Pink.
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
So, we are both big fans of my next guest.
He's an artist who works with musicians
to create one of a kind pieces
depicted in sound waves,
which is super rad.
Check out Sam Smith's "Stay With me."
That is so cool.
Then there's Celine Dion's
"My Heart Will Go On."
- [Pink] Oh, that's beautiful.
- [Kelly] Everyone's still
wondering why she's not
in the top 200, it's okay.
And look at this one.
This is Pink's own, "So What."
(audience cheering)
But this art isn't just beautiful, y'all.
It also helped raise nearly $7 million
for truly worthy charities.
Let's welcome the creator
of Soundwaves Art Foundation, Tim.
Give it up for Tim, y'all.
(audience cheering)
So it's great to meet you.
I know that y'all have
worked together a little bit
because I saw photos.
And I know that y'all worked together.
So how did you come up with this idea?
This is such a rad idea.
- So 15 years ago, I was a a music lover
and a fundraiser in London.
And I had this crazy idea
that I could become an artist
by capturing what essentially
is the heartbeat of a song
that you see in recording
studios all the time.
Those images that you see.
- Yeah.
- So I created some artwork
for Coldplay from "Yellow"
and I drove down to London in my truck.
And there isn't a sign
that says Coldplay Studio.
So I mean, I'm driving through London
and I find the alleyway
where it's supposed to be.
And I blocked the alleyway
and I'm looking for this studio
and this young guy comes along on a bike
and he takes three minutes to
lift the bike over my truck
and then puts it down.
And I'm just got my head, and I'm like,
I can't believe how embarrassing this is.
And I said, "Do you know
where Coldplay Studio is?"
And he says, "Yeah, I work here."
And he opened the door and I said,
"Could I leave some artwork
here for them to look at?"
And he took off his bike helmet
and it was Chris Martin from Coldplay.
- I was like, you know
what, I know the place.
Yeah. Yeah.
- I thought these guys
are never gonna sign.
So, but they're the
nicest guys in the world.
And they started the whole thing rolling.
And 15 years later, we've
had an amazing journey, so.
- That's my daughter's
favorite Coldplay song,
is "Yellow."
So now you work with hundreds
of the world's most notable artists.
So what's the process like?
- Essentially, we go to artists usually
who are touring in London or Austin,
'cause that's where we're based.
And we'll ask 'em if they
have a social justice issue
that they wanna support.
They'll choose a song,
and then I'll create
artwork from that song.
They'll then sign limited edition print
and original canvases,
and then they post it
on their social media.
And then their fans have
access to buy those.
A hundred percent of the
profit goes to charity.
So for instance, last year,
when the Ukrainian crisis started,
we reached out to musicians
who spoke about the issue,
like Barbara Streisand,
Robert Smith from The Cure,
the Pet Shop Boys.
And we've raised $600,000 just for,
thank you, thank you.
(audience cheering)
So Children in Conflict,
they provide safe spaces
for children who've
fled Ukraine, you know,
a lot of them have lost their parents.
- Lost everything.
- They're alone.
So they give them not
just food and education,
but counseling and
helping to come to terms
with what they've gone through.
So, that's-
- And will continue to go through. Yeah.
- So yeah, we're continuing
to do that this year.
And we are pledging 50,000 a month
to help keep safe spaces
open in the Ukraine.
- That's so cool.
- Thank you.
- So tell us what happened
when you reached out to Pink.
- So you've been on my
radar for a long time
and then you were
announced as the headliner
for Austin City Limits.
So we reached out to your team
and they came back with three songs.
"So what," "Just Give Me a Reason"
and "Cover Me In Sunshine."
And I created the artwork for you.
And gotta tell you, we've
worked with 500 musicians
in 15 years and when you posted,
it was the fastest selling
artwork we've ever had.
- Yay.
(audience cheering)
- There's like a few people
like her, like there's a few.
- We raised $40,000 in two hours
for No Kid Hungry and Unicef.
- Oh my gosh.
- We have a wait list of a thousand people
who want your artwork.
- Will you make more?
- Okay, anytime you like.
- Nice.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- But the best part of
it is that you asked
for an original piece-
- Yes, I did.
- And I hope you got it in your house.
- I do.
- And I hope you treasure it.
- I love it.
- It's been a pleasure and a privilege.
I've gotta be honest.
- That's so cool, man.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- All right, well, I'm excited
because I'm part of Tim's latest creation
and fundraising effort which
is right beneath this cloth.
It's an image of a song that I love.
It's called "Broken and Beautiful."
It's a song that I
recorded, but Pink wrote.
So I thought it would
be a perfect song to do.
(audience cheering)
I cannot wait to show it to the world.
Okay, so remove the
cover. I'll let you do it.
Or do you want me to help or you got it?
Okay.
- Good.
(audience cheering)
- [Pink] Oh, it's gorgeous.
- This is so rad.
This piece is going up for
auction today for just one week.
I'm thinking about
buying it myself (laughs)
and the proceeds will benefit
No Kid Hungry, everybody.
But first, we have to sign it.
So of course, we are gonna use
a Pilot silver paint marker.
As you know, Pilot is the maker of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
If you didn't know that, well, you should.
They like to celebrate unstoppable artists
just like Tim and us.
So you wanna go first?
- Sure.
- All right.
- Where do you wanna sign?
- [Pink] Where do you want the signatures?
- It's kind of fabulous.
- It's beautiful.
- I'm gonna bet on it.
- Signatures look really
lovely at the bottom-
- Okay.
Okay.
- If y'all see this in my
house in some photo (laughs).
Okay.
See, so Pink is athletic.
(audience cheering)
So, Pink is athletic.
So I was thinking I was
gonna sign over here
but I'm pulling a squat
in my Spanx and my dress.
Here we go, just kidding. Here we go.
- [Pink] That's beautiful.
- [Kelly] Boop, boop, boop.
Okay, and I'm getting up on my heel.
All right, everybody.
To bid on this piece and
support No Kid Hungry,
just go to The Kelly Clarkson
Show's Instagram right now.
It's for a good cause and good news,
everyone in the audience,
y'all are actually going home
with a print of "Broken and Beautiful."
(audience cheering)